[Musique]
le président mitteran à Moscou le
premier entretien de Michael gorbachov
et François mitteran en exclusivité dans
ce
journal perturbation dans les transports
parisiens grve dans le R est maintenant
dans le
métro la bagarre pour la mairie de
Marseille Robert vigourou marque un
point contre Michel
pzet au tableau d'honneur du vendredi la
semaine de la conscience soviétique les
victimes du
stalinisme madame monsieur bonsoir
bienvenue à Moscou bienvenue au kremelin
c'est ici à l'intérieur même de
l'endroit le plus secret du monde dans
ce salon pourpre qu'il y a quelques
instants Michael gorbachov et François
mitteran ont accordé en exclusivité un
entretien à Antenne 2 et à Europe le
président français est ici en visite
officielle il assistera demain à
baconour au lancement de la 2e mission
spatiale franco-soviétique il est 22h
ici à Moscou vous entendez peut-être la
pendule sonnée il fait froid -5 dehors
il neige mais le climat
franco-soviétique paraît excellent ce
soir mais si bien sûr les graves
troubles dans les républiques
soviétiques du Caucase sont présents
dans tous les esprits sur ce point
précis vous entendrez dans un moment la
première réponse de Michael gorbachov et
d'autres bien sûr mais d'abord le récit
de cette première après-midi à Moscou
Jean-Michel
Mercurol drapeau français et drapeau
rouge sur le nez du Concord même si
Moscou est sous la neige c'est bien vers
un réel réchauffement que s'achemineent
désormais les relations Fran
cosoviétique c'est la 5e fois que
François mitteran rencontre Michael
Gorbatchev deux réunions de travail
aujourd'hui et demain à Moscou avant le
départ de la mission spatiale
franco-soviétique à Baikonour l'occasion
de se parler était trop belle en cette
période de changement des données
diplomatiques un peu partout dans le
monde elle a été saisie par les deux
hommes sans attendre la visite d'État à
Paris au printemps prochain du numéro 1
soviétique pour parler politique d'abord
dans les salons du kremelin sur le
désarmement la réduction des forces
conventionnelles l'interdiction des
armes chimiques et les droits de l'homme
les deux hommes devaient aussi préciser
leur point de vue sur les modalités
d'organisation d'une conférence de paix
au Proche-Orient et sur leur vision
respective de l'avenir des Européens
ceux de l'Ouest et ceux de l'Est maises
relations commerciales et perspectives
économiques sont loin d'être absentes de
ce sommet puisque SEP ministres sont
venus en discuter avec leur homologue
soviétique la suite présidentielle
comprend en outre SEP grand patron
français industriels ou
banquier Messieurs les Présidents
bonsoir merci d'être sortis ensemble de
vos premiers entretiens d'abord un tête
à-tête je crois ensuite un entretien
élargi à vos délégations merci à vous
monsieur gorbachchov de nous accorder
ainsi votre premier entretien télévisé à
Antenne 2 et à Europe 1 merci alors on
entend beaucoup parler ici à Moscou
d'une espèce de stagnation dans les
rapports
anoviétique est-ce que vous estimez que
la France jusquici montré moins
enthousiaste vis-àvis de votre pays que
par exemple l'Allemagne fdérale l'Italie
la
grandebretne
prent
di
pr l k
Pr et la vie et la pratique des
relations internationales montre que
c'est un élément très important de du
dialogue
politique je dirais que j'apprécie
hautement et je ne crois pas trahir un
secret en parlant en présence de
Monsieur le Président j'apprécie le
niveau de dialogue qui existe entre le
président du Présidium du Soviet suprême
et le président de la République
française
nous étions unanimes avec monsieur le
Président pour dire que ce
dialogue de par sa
dynamique et son processus doit
correspondre au changements rapides qui
ont lieu dans le monde actuel et que le
rôle de l'Union soviétique et de la
France est tel que nous ne pouvons pas
nous
permettre le relâement du dialogue
politique
monsieur miteran vous avez soutenu très
ouvertement dans la presse française il
y a de jours la politique de Monsieur
gorbachov vous pensez vous aussi que ce
lien personnel est
indispensable je voudrais d'abord dire
que cette relation s'est établie depuis
déjà quelques années qu'elle a pris tout
son sens en
1985 lorsque Monsieur
Gorbatchov effectué son premier voyage
d'État dans un pays occidental
en France
précisément et l'année suivante j'ai
effectué à mon tour un voyage
d'État ce qui signifie tout un
décorum tout un rituel une
solenité qui bien entendu ne peut pas
être renouvelé chaque
fois et nous avons poursuivi ce dialogue
de toutes les façons et vous me dites
comment ce dialogue est-il
véritaableement mener pour qu'il soit
utile je crois qu'avec monsieur
Gorbatchov nous avons pris l'habitude de
nous parler
clairement si quelque chose ne nous
plaît pas nous le disons quand nous
avons le sentiment qu'il faut aller plus
loin dans la relation entre l'Union
soviétique et la France nous le faisons
et nous avons ainsi maintenant un
dialogue très cordial et je je le crois
confiant en tout cas certainement fécond
monsieur le Président sans vouloir vous
demander des détails techniques cas de
ce voyage nous avons tous remarqué que
vous étiez accompagnés du d'affaires
important d'industriel de ministre
économique alors est-ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à de nouveaux contrat disons
le mot important entre la France et
l'URSS qui nous mettrait un petit peu
moins loin derrière l'Allemagne derrière
l'Italie en ce qui concerne la
coopération économique avec ce pays on
peut s'attendre on peut s'attendre à de
nombreux accords de toutes sortes de
caractère public et de caractère privé
c'est une affaire de volonté et c'est
une question d'intérêt et notre intérêt
est
là la puissance publique l'état fait son
devoir les crédits sont ouverts il
appartient aussi aux entreprises privé
de faire l'effort qui convient et les
chefs d'entreprisees que j'ai amené à
Moscou dans ce voyage sont tous des
hommes dont on connaît l'envergure et le
dynamisme bien oui j'attends beaucoup
voyage quand on parle de crédit ouvert
nous pensons tous évidemment à ces
fameux 12 milliards de crédit les
crédits publics son ouvert des crédits
privés ça c'est une autre affaire qui se
traite par ceux qui en sont détenteurs
mais vous pensez que l'atmosphère de ces
conversation peut aider justement les
privés à bénéficier d'un bon accord
public j'espère que les relations
commerciales entre nos deux
paysifier et déjà rendez-vous est pris
pour l'année
prochaine on comprend à l'extérieur et
parf soutient la TR ici elle connaî des
difficultés quelqu résistan vous l'z
reconnu vousmême et même des risques
d'échec est-ce qu'elle continuera est-ce
que c'est un phénomène pour
vous la pestro est un choix qui a déjà
été fait non seulement par lesiges
politiques ou par les différents milieux
politiques mais par tout le
peuple cette pérestroïa nous l'appelons
révolutionnaire
elle amènera des transformations
profondes
elle nous permettra d'atteindre des
objectifs à long
terme c'est l'assurance d'une nouvelle
dimension pour notre
société et il est normal que lors d'une
transformation de cette ampleur il y ait
toujours des discussions des échanges
d'opinion en ce qui concerne les
objectifs et le processus de la
proïa
temp discussion nous ont déjà enrichi à
mon avis nous avons la politique de la
pérest trïa qui comprend l'économie le
processus politique l'idéologie mais je
crois que
l'essentiel c'est la poïa dans
lesit et c'est un processus qui n'est
pas simple je dirais même que c'est un
processus douloureux la difficulté n'est
pas d au fait que quelqu'un refuse la
pestroïa ils ne sont pas nombreux et ce
n'est pas eux qui définissent l'opinion
publique non la société est pour la
pérestroïque
les difficultés sont dans le processus
luiême nous devons couper avec notre
passé nous devons maîtriser les
nouvelles méthodes d'action et d'esprit
dans tous les domaines et ce n'est
jamais
simpleousendre que des événements série
tension sérieérou entre peuples s les et
les Arméniens comment pensez-vous
ramener le calme entre ces deux peuples
voisin
vous savez ça fait partie de la p
Troïa dans notre pays qui compte autant
d'ethnie de culture et de langu nous ne
pouvons résoudre aucun problème sans
tenir compte de cette
particularité maintenant que la
pérestroïa prend de
l'élan ce processus concerne les
intérêts des différents peuples ess en
plus la pérestroïa la glace noost la
démocratie ont permis à tous les peuples
d'exprimer leurs opinions quant à leur
état de santé quant aux problèmes qui se
sont accumulés dans notre énorme
fédération nous sommes donc en train de
discuter de tous ces problèmes parmi
lesquels il y a des problèmes anciens
qui se sont
accumulés dans les
relations entre les peuples les peuples
voisin par exemple le hautab c'est un
problème ancien je crois que la solution
de ce problème passe par l'entente mais
nous attons et nous voulons contribuer à
ce que c
entente apparaisse à ce qu'il y ait le
terrain d'entente qu'il n'y ait pas de
rupture entre les liens anci
Rees
peuples
qu'on a l'attitude attentive à l'égard
de ce problème je crois que malgré l'acé
qu' revê le problème à présent il y a
une
aggravation Némo nous croyons que la
solution passe par la coopération par la
mise en place de la
coopération en échangeant calmement less
deue sur la meilleure façon de sortir de
cette situation prochainement les
dirigeants soviétiques rencontreront la
délégation arméindienne la délégation
Azé nous serons nous nous mettrons à
trois parties pour discuter de la
meilleure façon de trouver la solution
qui soit conforme aux intérêt de ces
deux peuples et dans l'intérêt de toute
l'Union de de tout notre notre pays bien
entendu notre pays se préoccupe monsieur
le Président vous ne craignez pas qu'à
cette occasion certaines forces
conservatrices qui peut-être sont encore
plutôt rétisente vis-àvis de votre
politique ne trouve une raison de
signifier plus fortement leur
opposition je question de ce qui de ce
qui suit tout comme dans d'autres
républiques là aussi il se trouve des
gens qui ont l'attitude dououreuse à
l'égard de
la
il chercherai à détourner l'attention
des des gens à détourner leur attention
sur les problèmes tels que learab là il
y a le problème mais nous nous ne
l'ignorons pas et nous sommes loin de de
faire
l'amalgame tout ce qui touche aux
relation entre deux ethnies cela fait
l'objet de notre de notre attitude très
attentive et nous ferons le nécessaire
pour harmoniser de tel Rapp
mais cela n'affaiblira pas pour autant
notre détermination à faire en sorte que
les éléments corrompus et les éléments
antisociaux qui voi que la pérestroa
empiète sur leurs intérêts
égoïste ils veulent donc Sapper la PA
nous nous serons ad admettre une telle
situation et ne pourrons y faire face
monsieur le Président depuis pour la
première fois ici même auelin vous AZ
ten le nom de sa carotte et vous avez
parlé des droits de l'homme grâce à
Monsieur Gorbatchev il y a eu des
progrès quel type d'évolution quel type
de progrès vous attendz sur les droits
de l'homme avant qu'il y ait peut-être
cette conférence qut on parle pour 1991
quel type d'avance c'est
nouvell ces progrès sont
évidents tout le monde le sait et
vous-même journalistes on tenz
informé la France et les journalistes du
monde entier les autres s on sait bien
qu'il se passe quelque chose de très
important en Union soviétique et que ce
quelque chose va dans le sens d'une plus
grande ouverture d'une plus grande
liberté et il me semble que c'est le
mouvement du monde pris dans son bon
sens dans sa bonne direction est-ce que
cela peut correspondre aujourd'hui à
l'idée que je me fais démocratie t que
nous les pratiquons dans le monde
occidental non est-ce que la comparaison
à établir entre ce qui est accompli sous
l'autorité de Monsieur Gorbatchov et ce
qui a été pendant un certain temps la
réalité de l'Union soviétique
naturellement chacun sait bien que cela
présente beaucoup de courage politique
beaucoup d'effort et une grande vision
de l'avenir alors moi je regarde cela on
peut pas toujours se référer à sa propre
règle il faut observer aussi de quelle
manière l'évolution se fait c'est d's la
question que vous me posez parl en effet
de professeur sakarov au kremelin
d'ailleurs devant Monsieur gorbachov
c'était aut temp de son prédécesseur bon
très bien les droits de l'homme c'est un
domaine qui fait partie de la discussion
permanente décidé dans les accords
d'hsinki et les partenaires les 35
partenaires de la conférence en question
parle des droits de l'homme comme il
parle des autres
questions l'Union soviétique
autant que nous et avec nous on ne peut
donc pas traiter du problème des droits
de l'homme sans l'Union soviétique
puisque les signataires avec nous des
accords
d'helsinkion alors il a été demandé une
conférence sur les droits de l'homme en
1989 l'an prochain bicentenaire à
Paris l'année suivante à Copenhague
l'année suivante donc en 91 à Moscou
bien entendu ça pose des questions elles
ont été posées et les puissances
occidentales sont en train d'en discuter
d'en faire l'examen afin de savoir dans
quelles conditions cette conférence
pourrait se tenir il n'empêche que
l'Union soviétique est un partenaire est
un de nos partenaires pour discuter des
droits de l'homme en Europe voilà ce que
j'ai pu dire
d'accord d'accord et nous en avons
parlé nous réfléchissons à l'Europe
notre maison commune
nous y vivons déjà nous sommes
différents c'est une bonne
chose nous
respectons chaque peuple respecte les
autres nous devons respecter le choix
fait par les autres nous n'avons pas la
prétension d'imposer nos valeurs aux
autres mais nous escontons pour
également que dans cette maison là dans
cet appartement de la Maison européenne
on on ne nous impose pas de statut
particulier mais cela n'exclut pas pour
autant les
échanges les
échanges sur le plan politique les
échanges culturel les échanges quant à
l'organisation de la vie de la société
et probablement au cours de ce processus
il y aurait le rapprochement continu
entre les peuples vivants sur ce vieux
continent nous sommes persuadés que
l'Europe a beaucoup de
chance de
voir la constitution de la maison d'une
véritable maison commune à tous les
Européens qui aura pour la base les les
valeurs propre à l'humanité tout entière
et le respect
réciproque nous avons parlé beaucoup
avec le président et là
nous nous concernons les les choses
concrètes il y a également les problèmes
concrets
traités pendant nos conversations pour
l'instant nous discutons de ces futures
conférences avec nos
alliés les traités indiquent que nous
devons discuter des droits de l'homme
avec tous les partenaires de l'Europe
également les Américains et les
Canadiens parmi les partenaires
européens on peut dire que l'Union
soviétique particulièrement importante
donc c'est normal qu'on en
discute quant à la maison commune c'est
une très belle expression don monsieur
gorbachov est l'auteur
bien entendu c'est une une vue à
distance comment pourrait-on être contre
alors il faut réaliser un certain nombre
de conditions pour y parvenir d'ailleurs
nous de notre côté nous sommes en train
de construire une Europe celle de la
communauté nous sommes 12 et nous allons
en quelques années 4 ans bâtir un marché
unique entre nous cela va créer de
nouvelles conditions de la vie
économique de l'Europe mais ilter avec
eu également mais naturellement et a
beaucoup de problèmes qui
échappe à la division de l'Europe prenez
le problème de
l'environnement prenez le problème de
hautes
technologies à tout moment cela passe
par-dessus les
frontières et nous devons commencer à
faire l'Europe de cette manière faut-il
parler de la
télévision notre Europe la partie de
l'Europe où se trouve monsieur
gorbachchov et celle où se trouve la
France sont extraordinairement
déficitair dans la production des images
qui vont absolument comment dirais-je
peux dire fabriquément fait
impressionner tout le le cerveau et donc
les formes de culture d'intelligence de
de tous les enfants de d'Europe avec nos
cultures nos traditions nos
civilisations nos expressions à nous
tous mais nous sommes de la même source
nous voudrions pas que que cela searisse
au bénéfice uniquement des des images
américaines et de la technologie
japonaise ça ça passe par-dessus la
frontière la division de l'Europe
pourquoi ne pas mettre ça d'lon avec des
définitions qui nous soient communes
enfin les exemples seraient nombreux je
parlé deenvironnement la protection de
la nature qu'est-ce que vous voulez
quand quand la forêt est malade elle est
aussi bien en Scandinavie qu' qu'en
Union soviétique ou bien que dans les
bouges monsieur miteran vous connaissez
bien George Bush qui vient d'être élu le
prochain président des États-Unis vous
aussi monsieur gorbach vous le
connaissez bien vous allez déjeuner je
crois à New York dans une dizaine de
jours avec Monsieur Rean et Monsieur
Bush est-ce que vous pensez l'un et
l'autre que cette nouvelle
administration américaine va accélérer
les discussions en cours notamment sur
le désarmement monsieur
gorb je répondrai brièvement à la
question que vous venez de poser nous
espérons la continuité dans les
relations
sovi-américaines et nous espérons que
deel RA
prog
l'aghanistan vous avez annonc ça été
spectaculaire le retrait des troupes
soviétiques d'Afghanistan et puis une
suspension du retrait est-ce que le 17
février 89 monsieurev il y aura des
unités constitué soviétiqu encore en
Afghanistan
sign qui plus nous
espérons que nos
partenaires pour de tels accords seront
aussi responsables que nous pourquoi je
le dis c'est que pour l'instant cette
responsabilité leur fait défaut or nous
invitons nos partenaires à adopter cette
attitude responsable qui plus est nous
réfléchissons à la question de savoir
comment seront appliqués les les accords
de Genève et nous considérons le respect
de tels accords combien de pierres de
touche pour tester l'attitude de nos
partenaires dans la perspective de de la
réalisation de grand de grands accords
il y a beaucoup de de conflits où devons
n nous devrions coopérer
aussi aussi avons-nous l'espoir de la
coopération nous continuerons de rester
attachés aux accords adopt à Genève nous
savons que vous allez parler avec
Monsieur gorb de désarmement alors il y
a des Français qui disent ma fois
l'Union soviétique construit en une
semaine autant de char que la France en
un an que signifie le désarmement ce qui
est posé une façon un peu simpliste la
question des armes dites
conventionnelles alors est-ce que il va
y avoir un progrès dans ce domaine de
l'équilibre il y a des formes d'armes
différentes et il y a des discussions
naturellement
différentes pas une discussion globale
sur le désarmement il y a eu d'abord
l'accord de Washington entre monsieur
gorbachchov et Monsieur Rean sur euh la
suppression des armes nucléaires dites
intermédiaire c'est-à-dire faisant une
poré une distance entre 1000 entre 500
et 4500 km très bien cet accord est fait
c'est excellent accord
ensuite il a été question d'un
désarmement stratégique nucléaire de
réduire même de 50 % l'armement
américain et l'armement soviétique qui
est très puissant moi je sais pas quel
est le chiffre exact mais je me
hasarderai en disant d'au moins 12000
charges nucléaires de part et d'autre
très bien c'est une très bonne nouvelle
il y a le désarmement conventionnel nous
y sommes pour l'instant on en discute
précisément à la conférence sur la
sécurité la confiance en Europe à 35
pays ou plutôt des pays intéressés par
ces problèmes d'armement conventionnel
par pas des pays neutres des pays qui
sont étrangers à cela discute
précisément mais dans le cadre de la
conférence dans des conventionnelles
nous y sommes nous allons charger un
certain nombre de nos représentants les
ministres les ambassadeurs de d'engager
la discussion concrète mais dans les
dans les jours qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent la réponse à votre
question sera apporté à ce moment-là
mais il est nécessaire à mes yeux de
rétablir un équilibre entre les forces
classiques les avions les
chars l'artillerie com on les
connaissait avant l' éire entre l'Est et
l'Ouest cela paraî nécessaire et puis il
y a le désarmement chimique nous avons
rendez-vous à Paris pour une grande
conférence internationale il y a 110
pays signataires de la conférence de
1925 sont tous invités puis quelques
autres pardessus le
marchéchiant pourrait parler du
désarmement biologique mais la France ne
fabrique pas ces choses donc je m'arrête
là chaque avancée du désarmement sera
une bonne nouvelle pour le monde
quant à la France elle j'ai indiqué dès
1983 à la tribune des Nations uniques
qu'elle prendrait part au désarmement
notamment
nucléaire le jour où nous aurions
constaté un certain nombre de conditions
remplies dans le désarmement des deux
plus grandes puissances on en est là
comment vous définissez l'étape actuelle
des relations franco-soviétiques est-ce
que c'est une étape nouvelle vous allez
de coopération comment vous la
définissez les les
relations personnelles avec monsieur le
gbalson Président du présidium suprême
ont été établis sur une base que je
crois confiante et en tout cas
approfondie claire depuis maintenant
déjà 3 ans nous avons même pris de
l'avance sur un certain nombre d'autres
partenaires et nous continuons nous ne
nous sommes pas vu c'est vrai en 1987
mais nous nous sommes vu en 85 en 86
nous nous voyons maintenant à l'occasion
car il faut pas l'oublier
de du lancement de cosmonaute à baonour
où je vais demain c'est ça l'origine de
mon voyage puce que le général chrétien
sera lancé dans l'espace pour y
séjourner sortir dans l'espace pendant
quelques semaines et bien entendu cette
association qui entre homme et en
technologie sur la base des expériences
soviétiques c'est une manifestation
particulièrement concrète d'une bonne
entente entre l'Union soviétique et la
France et sur un bon terrain bon
alors nous allons continuer et puis
chaque fois qu'il y aura un obstacle en
a de temps en
temps celui qui n'en sera pas satisfait
moi le premier dira non ça nous
empêchera pas de continuer à tenter de
réussir un bon accord avec ce grand pays
auquel nous devons beaucoup car ceux de
ma génération se souviennent que pendant
la dernière guerre mondiale l'Union
soviétique a pris une large part à notre
liberté
monsieur le Président Monsieur le le
président merci 1000 fois au nom
d'Antenne 2 d'Europe 1 et de tous les
téléspectateurs français et européens
qui vont grâce à vous avoir des
précisions tout à fait passionnantes sur
l'état des relations bilatérales
franco-soviétiques bien sûr mais aussi
sur un certain nombre de dossiers
d'actualité merci donc à vous deux à
vous Paris à vous HERV Claude à tout de
suite Christine en France les problèmes
sociaux toujours à commencé par la grève
dans le RER la nociation est dans
l'impasse le conflit oppose je vous le
rappelle les agents d'entretien du RER
et la direction dès ce soir il n'y avait
plus qu'un train sur trois sur les
lignes A et B les 600000 voyageurs
quotidiens du RER ont bien des
difficultés à rentrer chez eux un espoir
d'amélioration tout à l'heure le juge
des référés de Nanterre a ordonné
l'évacuation des voies occupées dans
deux ateliers de Boulogne biancour et de
rueille l'évacuation doit s'effectuer
sous 24 heures cela permettra peut-être
au trafic de reprendre d'ici lundi ce
soir la greffe commencé d'ailleurs à
gagner le métro parisien pour l'instant
la direction et la CGT campent sur leur
position difficulté encore dans les bus
à Marseille et encore à la SNCF sur la
ligne parimante par exemple en politique
annulation de deux élections
législatives notamment celle de
guyessier c'est lui qui avait gagné de
84 voix face à Bernard tapi il y a eu
des irrégularités dans cette
circonscription de Marseille l'élection
de l'UDF guitessier est donc annulé
autre annulation celle de François
assensi du Parti communiste en S saintn
alors à propos de la première annulation
écoutez la réaction de Bernard tapi il
évoque la possibilité d'une nouvelle
campagne électorale
écoutez si j'ai le sentiment personnel
vrai de pouvoir plutôt arranger la
situation en en faisant en sorte qu'il y
ait moins de conflit euh intérieur euh
et extérieur j'irai si au contraire j'ai
le sentiment que ça complique davantage
la situation qui est déjà très
compliquée il me semble qu'à ce
moment-là le devoir m'obligera de ne pas
dire all et de laisser les
professionnels entre eux à un moment où
il faut le reconnaître ces élections
risquent d'être plus importantes qu'ell
l'étent lors des élections législatives
à Marseille la bagare pour la mairie
suite Robert vigourou le maire actuel a
marqué un point en effet Michel pzé le
candidat officiel du Parti socialiste
souhaiter un redécoupage des
circonscriptions à Marseille pierre Jox
ministre de l'Intérieur a dit non et il
l'a fait savoir au députés socialiste de
l'Assemblée c'est un accro sérieux entre
le gouvernement et le Parti socialiste
écoutez ce qu'en pense monsieur vigourou
j'ai apprécié l'esprit républicain et
également la la rigueur
et la responsabilité du du ministre de
l'Intérieur qui n'a pas voulu que qu'il
y ait un un amendement accroché surtout
à une loi antifraude pour Marseille
c'était c'était curieux quand même j'ai
interrogé des
Marseillais je crois que ça ne faisait
pas tellement plaisir à à la population
de se sentir ainsi découpé coupé il y a
des lois qui existent euh
l'échanger juste à la dernière
minute ça choque Roland Duma le ministre
français des Affaires étrangères va se
rendre en Iran le principe du voyage a
été retenu la date n'a pas encore été
arrêtée deux morts neuf blessés c'est le
bilan d'un raid israélien au Sud Liban
la chasse israélienne a attaqué une base
sunnite celle qui contrôle la ville de
saidda en France deux jeunes gens
arrêtés à Paris et déférés au parc ils
sont soupçonnés d'être liés au groupe
Action directe et notamment à IET B la
passionnaria du groupe Action Directe
récemment libéré aux assises de bobini
le jugement dans l'affaire de Patrick
savret ce policier accusé de meurtre
d'un jeune beur à pentin l'avocat
général avait réclamé 8 ans de réclusion
verdict de la cour 7 ans à Athènes des
milliers d'Athéniens ont rendu un
dernier hommage à Christina Onasis la
fille de l'armateur qui est morte le
weekend dernier en Argentine sera
enterrée demain dans l'île de Scorpios
la propriété de sa famille aujourd'hui
sa dépouille mortelle vous le voyez
était exposée dans une église
d'Athènes et pour terminer ce rapide
survol de l'actualité je vous rappelle
deux rendez-vous importants demain en
sport roumanie- France de rugby c'est à
15h ce sera en direct sur Antenne 2 et
puis juste avant à 13h20 la finale des
Championnats du Monde d'orthographe ce
sera au théâtre de chillot Bernard Pivot
lira la dicté et ce sera encore en
direct sur Antenne 2 mais ce soir
l'événement c'est encore bien sûr sur
Antenne 2 c'est Moscou en direct pour la
visite de François miteran à Michael
Gorbatchev nous retrouvons tout de suite
christino krent au crremelin Christine
oui Hervé ici à Moscou le drapeau
tricolore flotte sur le kremelin mais
c'est dans une datcha près de Moscou
qu'en ce moment même Michael et Raissa
Gorbatchev reçoivent à dîner en tout
petit comité Monsieur et Madame mitteran
les médias soviétiques font état bien
sûr de cette visite française il faut
bien le dire qu'ils ne disent pas un mot
des graves troubles qui continuent donc
dans les républiques du Caucase l'armée
soviétique cadrie toujours Bacou où le
couvre-feu est maintenu couvre-feu aussi
à herevan la capitale de l'Arménie où la
grève aurait été générale aujourd'hui
Michael gorbachchov vous l'avez entendu
tout à l'heure a tenu un langage
extrêmement ferme il a aussi annoncé
qu'il réunirait de deux délégations une
délégation d'Arménien une délégation
azerie pour discuter de la situation ce
qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que la
politique des nationalités
mené dans ce pays depuis 1917 est bien
mal en point aub
hEDLER le temps des pogromes semble
revenu dans le conflit qui oppose depuis
9 mois les deux républiques soviétiques
hier à kirovabad les azéis auraient
lancé une véritable chasse
antiarménienne il y aurait plusieurs
morts des centaines de blessés de
nombreux Arméniens tentant de gagner
Yerevan la capitale de l'Arménie voisine
Yerevan d'où en juillet dernier nous
parviennent les premières imees des
manifestations nationalistes destinées à
obtenir leur attachement à l'Arménie du
nagornikarabach région d'Azerbaïdjan
peuplé d'une majorité d'Arméniens ni
l'intransigence de Moscou ni le
déploiement de l'armée ne pourront
enrayer les violences et les
manifestation particulièrement massive
ces jours derniers à Bakou la capitale
aérie mais c'est un ton nouveau que
prend désormais ce conflit entre deux
peuples cristallisé sur l'avenir du
nagornikarabachh ce sont maintenant deux
ethnies qui se retrouvent face à face
musulmans azéis contre chrétiens
arméniens qui remettent tragiquement en
cause 70 ans d'une politique des
nationalités dont le fondement naura pu
résister au premier siges de détente
apparu au kremelin
oui quelle que soit l'évolution de la
situation intérieure dans son pays
Michael Gorbatchev passera en tout cas
l'essentiel de la matinée de demain avec
François miteran et ses ministres le
président ira ensuite à Baikonour c'est
à 16h50 heure française qu'une fusée
soyuse lancera dans l'espace une deuxème
mission spatiale franco-soviétique la
coopération sur ce plan s'accélère
d'ailleurs il est question ici ce soir
d'un nouvel accord franco-soviétique qui
assurait une participation régulière
française un mois tous les 2 ans donc
sur les vols habités soviétique pour le
moment Jean-Lou chrétien vit à
baayconour les dernières heures sur
terre avant le départ sur place Patric
Eser 6h du matin dans le brouillard du
Kazakhstan pour la fusé zemorka chargé
d'emporter Jean-Lou chrétien dans
l'espace le voyage commence à
l'horizontale sur une voie de chemin de
fer arrivé sur le pas de tir la fusée
est redressée en quelques minutes à la
verticale avant que ne commence le
remplissage des réservoirs contenant 270
tonnes de carburant demain à 16h46
Jean-Lou chrétien se trouvera au sommet
de cette
fusée il y a toujours l'appréhension des
d'événements aussi insolides que le
décollage sur une machine volante que ce
soit une fusée ou que ce soit un avion
moderne les avions auxquels on est
habitué donc ça c'est c'est c'est ça
peut être une appréhension ça peut être
une un sujet de réflexion
mais là il y a un aspect professionnel
il y a une réaction professionnelle ça
fait 20 ans 30 ans même qu'on qu'on
s'habitue à ce genre de réaction ici au
musée de baaykenour une vitrine est
consacrée au premier vol que jean-l
chrétien avait effectué en
1982 les boîtes de nourriture spatiale
française il côtoie la photo du général
de Gaulle venu assister à un lancement
en
1966 demain dans ce grand hall
d'assemblage les Soviétiques
présenteront au président mitteran leur
tout nouveau scafandre spatial autonome
la motocyclette pour cosmonautes comme
il l'appelle suprême marque d'honneur
les Soviétiques feront également voir
leur navette spatiale
burouran et Moscou
22h40 presque Moscou sous la neig
la capitale de cet immense empire que la
volonté d'un homme essaie d'entraîner
vers de nouvelles voies et aussi vers de
nouvelles mémoires ainsi à Moscou cette
semaine est celle de la conscience de
jeunes historiens soviétiques ont réussi
à retrouver la trace de 134000 victimes
fusillées par Staline sur les quelques
34 millions de morts de la période du
stalinisme cette initiative est grâce à
Gill Rabine et George ansen à notre
tableau d'honneur de la
[Musique]
SEM un livret de
famille
temp
certifation la dernière lettre
reçue pvre reli pour un dernier espoir
apprendre enfin comment est mort un mari
arrêté par la police de Staline une nuit
de l'hiver
[Musique]
1937 autour du mur de la mémoire la
quête des victimes anonymes de
Staline arrêté à 15 ans et
fusillé dépé avec sa femme fille
Témo
37 si vous avez connu mon père
téléphonez-moi écrit
gouac on m'a enfin donné un manteau avec
les 30 roubl que tu m' envoyé je vais
pouvoir acheter des
bottes auudessus de la photo du père
fusiller le certificat de
réhabilitationéit sa
il
ave qui était
Staline moi je sais c'est celui qui tu s
frères Stal envoyé des gens dans des de
concentration des milliers de
gens
cette mère se découvre complice
involontaire du stalinisme mes parents
ont cru en Staline toute leur vie
expliqueelle devant son fils moi
aussi un monument au Vic de Staline sera
érigé un jour à Moscou peut-être avec
l'argent des
familles
monument provisoire 134000 noms de
fusillers retrouvés un par un par des
étudiants
l'histoire on fusillait parfois les
enfants avec les parents alors nous
avons caché notre fils de 3 ans chez un
ami ils sont venus en pleine nuit moi
j'ai réussi à me sauver par mon mari il
a été
fusilé j'ai été déportée à 18 ans parce
que j'étais enceinte de marine américain
mon fiancé n'a jamais su qu'il avait une
fille et une petite fille je travaillais
dans le Grand Nord à la construction
d'une ligne de chemin de fer au camp du
kilomè501 levé à 7h une sou 12 he de
travail sur la TRA la neige les chiens
de garde tous les jours pendant 6
ans
elle pleure sur les années stalines la
honte des décennies de silence qui ont
suivi et sur les rêves perdus du
communisme voilà merci d'être rester un
peu plus longtemps avec nous un peu plus
longtemps que d'habitude grâce àre qui
était aux manettes et à la collaboration
de la télévision soviétique je crois que
grâce à toute l'équipe qui s'est
mobilisée ici à Moscou avec Alain vider
je crois que nous comprenons un peu
mieux ce soir la politique soviétique et
aussi l'ambiance qui règne autour de
michaell gorbachchov que vous aurez vu
d'un peu plus près demain sur antenne de
toujours en direct ne manquez pas à
16h50 heure française le lancement de la
fusierée spatiale à baaykenour dans un
instant Laurent Cabrol va vous parler du
temps en France très bonne soirée sur
Antenne 2 bon weekend et à
[Musique]
lundi